our next guest is Natasha Leggero she's
known for her honest very honest sharp
comedy like this one in her 2015
stand-up special
I just want to know what that feeling is
that moms talk about like new moms are
like it's the most amazing feeling
Natasha you can't get it from a
Chihuahua it cracks you open and you're
born again like I just want to know what
that feeling is for like 10 seconds
if it's worth looking that awful because
the comedian and actress who also made
Regular appearances on Chelsea Lately
did decide to take the plunge into
motherhood she now has a four-year-old
little girl with her husband fellow
comedian Moshe kosher so you know that's
fun in their house Rogero writes about
being a mom in her new book The World
deserves my children it's published by
an imprint of Simon and Schuster I love
this cover which like CBS is a division
of Paramount Global we're very very
excited to welcome
Natasha Leggero in the studio mom thanks
for having me I was wondering because
you said you always thought of your
career as a child you never wanted a kid
and you said being a mom is sort of like
uh being in a horror movie you survive
Freddy but Jason is in the kitchen well
it's the idea mom I like this it's like
being a waitress in a real crappy
restaurant where people don't tip so
you're enjoying motherhood and the
people leave their underwear on the
floor
I am enjoying it but the Freddy thing is
like you know people would always say
never never you know you're never gonna
feel this much love and it's you can't
explain it but I didn't understand that
love and fear were interchangeable and
you're once you get over one fear then
it's like the next fear and I'm assuming
the high school years are easy Gail yeah
they are but I loved every stage I mean
you go from I never thought about
choking and now you're the mom in the
kitchen cutting up a grape into fours I
know and I never I I was always someone
who was filled with so much guate of Eve
you know I was never afraid of anything
and then you have this baby and the
stakes are so high and it's just I think
physiologically it's just so much for a
woman to handle I mean not that you men
don't have it hard but yeah come on now
but you worked really hard to get this
baby I did I froze my eggs at 38 and
that's kind of the cut off if anyone's
you know that's thinking about it and
then I was able to get pregnant at 43
but you know it's uh but what you what
it took for you to get pregnant was a
lot a lot and went through a lot of pain
and when I froze my eggs I didn't
realize you know he said I had eight
eggs so I thought that meant eight
babies and I'm like I barely want one
yes but what I didn't realize is they
have to like you know fertilize them
turn them into embryos test them I only
had four that survived then after they
tested them two one didn't work and then
the last one is my darling one yeah yeah
so what's your advice to women who want
to have kids freeze your eggs oh yes we
get two extra you guys wouldn't
understand this but we get school me up
talk to me girl two extra decades now
for women to like you know earn money
and uh live your life live your life
meet a partner that you actually you
know love right right not be in that
Panic speaking of Partners I heard you
and the husband got some different
different parentings yes it is so hard
parenting with a man I mean truly like
as a woman I would have to have five
drinks and be an amputee for my
parenting style to be equal to that of a
so Uber father like I don't know what he
thinks is no no what are these people
thinking Natasha you tell a funny story
that if if the husband spends 45 minutes
with the child they think they need a
spa day yeah
they don't know where anything is does
she think y'all are funny
she does she does she has just started
saying mom please don't say anything I
say to anyone oh and I'm like oh so
she's already starting she's got a
little size did she get that from you of
course yes uh I mean I don't know if she
understands what I do for a living but I
am going to be talking about her but
your title is interesting because I had
a different take when it said the world
deserves my children and the way you're
looking I thought you were saying oh God
please take my children away that isn't
what you're saying well and you say the
world deserves my children because I
work so hard they work so hard to get
here well because that Journey yes that
journey of her fight that one embryo
surviving was like so because the doctor
told me you know there's really less
than a 30 chance that this is going to
happen for you with the amount of eggs
that you got so yes I do feel that and
also you know I did it in covid and
there's a lot of talk about you know the
world is in the state should we be even
having children and I do feel that you
know we can't just let the idiots have
kids yes yeah there's also Natasha you
said a lot of judgment Mothers Against
mothers which I think is so true that is
true yeah it is true you have an
interesting take on that well you look
up like you know I don't know how to
parent I tell jokes for a living so you
know you look up all these things and
they're like there's all these new ways
of parenting and being like permissive
and you know making sure that they're
validated and their feelings and don't
say no and yes you know and it's just
like don't say good job because it
sounds like good dog yeah they'll fail s
you're supposed to say you worked really
hard on that which is kind of
condescending I don't know want another
one yeah want another one do I want
another kid
no no no no no no no no no no no no
I thought you were offering do you want
another joke
thank you congratulations oh thank you
your husband and your favorite daughter
thank you good to have you here
Natasha's book is called the world
deserves my children it's on sale right
now wherever you like to buy your books
or the audiobook or the audiobook audio
we'll be right back